en china los recolectores de basura son
quienes más han estado a cargo del
reciclaje pero desde 2019 los residentes
de las grandes ciudades deben clasificar
sus residuos o de lo contrario se
arriesgan a pagar una multa para ayudar
con el proceso también se han creado
empresas como aubach sus usuarios pueden
ganar dinero dejando los artículos o
recicladores limpios en las estaciones
que funcionan las 24 horas del día
en esta estación se ponen las bolsas de
reciclaje llenas de artículos de
plástico
luego tienen que escanear el código qr
de una nueva bolsa para vincularla a su
cuenta y se la puede llevar a casa para
seguir reciclando
te mato
una clientela de todas las edades
ecológica pero también ahora activa es
más práctico venir a esta estación de
reciclaje que venderles nuestra basura a
los recolectores puedo venir aquí cuando
quiera puede vender otro tipo de
desechos aquí si muchos más y esta
estación está cerca de mi casa un
sistema que le permite a obama reducir
sus costos
como los residentes clasifican su basura
por nosotros eso nos ahorra tiempo y
trabajo y aumenta nuestra productividad
la omnipresencia de las aplicaciones
móviles en china les da otra ventaja
gracias a los códigos qr y el
seguimiento la empresa puede notificar a
los usuarios cuando dejan un artículo
que no se ajusta a los criterios si no
les damos feedback a nuestros usuarios
sobre nuestro sistema de reciclaje no
sabrán si cometieron errores en la
clasificación de las basuras alvac
quiere educar a la gente
un papel alentado por el estado que
invirtió en la empresa para mejorar la
clasificación de residuos en el país
uno de los objetivos de las nuevas leyes
es eliminar gradualmente los plásticos
de un solo uso
en 2020 del sector de la entrega de
comidas en china despacho casi 17.000
millones de pedidos
y actualmente los usuarios deben elegir
si quieren cubiertos desechables o japex
usa
amex autores antes de finalizar el
pedido uno tiene que elegir si quiere
cubiertos o no como yo quiero utilizar
un mínimo de plástico elijo no pedir y
ahora puedo pagar
una pequeña acción que puede cambiar la
conducta de la gente en un país en el
que la conciencia ecológica ha tardado
en aparecer
cuando el servicio de entrega se
popularizó me gustaba mucho solía pedir
mucho porque es muy práctico después me
di cuenta de que cada vez tenía más
cajas de plástico después de cada comida
votaba mucha basura y eso me preocupaba
yo con los jóvenes sobre todo los que
tienen estudios superiores prestan
atención a esto y quieren respetar las
normas
pero el cambio de mentalidad es sólo una
de las muchas batallas en la guerra
contra el plástico bueno songo'o es uno
de los que diseñó la nueva política de
plásticos de china está orgulloso de los
progresos que ha hecho en el país pero
sabe que aún queda mucho camino por
recorrer
hay nuevas normas pero su aplicación no
está lo suficientemente supervisada
todavía no existe ningún mecanismo para
supervisar su aplicación a largo plazo
se puede decir que algunos sectores
todavía no están haciendo lo suficiente
para reducir realmente la contaminación
por plásticos es el caso de la entrega
de comidas y paquetes a estos dos
sectores son enormes en china y crecen
rápidamente y es difícil controlar la
contaminación por plásticos que generan
renta y para aquellos que hicieron todo
lo posible por respetar las nuevas
normas no siempre fue fácil las pajitas
de plástico están oficialmente
prohibidas desde enero de este año el
gerente de este bar de jugos tuvo que
cambiar su línea de productos sin
espantar a sus clientes
en octubre del año pasado empezamos a
utilizar pajitas de cartón para
sustituir las de plástico
también desarrollamos un producto que se
puede beber sin pajita consigo
utilizamos botellas y pajitas que son de
plástico reciclable
pero no siempre se puede complacer a
todo el mundo
prefiero las pajitas de plástico las de
cartón se ablandan con el agua
las nuevas páginas también son de 5 a 6
veces más caras que las de plástico pero
el señor gao no se arrepiente
no sufrimos económicamente debido a esta
nueva política los comerciantes lo
entendemos y los consumidores también
a pesar de estos esfuerzos el río
yangtsé vierte cada año 15 millones de
toneladas de plástico en el océano esta
contaminación histórica acumulada
durante varias décadas es uno de los
próximos retos para las autoridades
chinas